The 15th
most common misconception regarding
Islam amongst the non-Muslim is
that why in Islam
two woman witnesses is equal to one
witness of man. Isn't this injustice?
Why are two women witness equal to one
witness of man?
Let me tell you at the outset that in
all the cases two women witness is not
equal to one witness of man. There are
no less than eight verses in the Quran
which talk about witness but doesn't
specify whether it's male or female.
There is one incident in which the Quran
does mention
that two women witness is equal to one.
It's in surah bakra chapter number two
verse number 282 which is the longest
verse of the Quran and Allah says oh you
believe when you involve yourself in any
transaction which involves future
obligation
put it down in writing
and take amongst yourself two just men
as witnesses
and IF YOU CANNOT FIND two men take one
man
and two women so that if one makes a
mistake the second will remind her. So
this is the longest verse of the Quran
and is talking about financial
transaction.
So only in financial transaction Allah
says in the Quran when you involve
yourself in a transaction involving
future obligation take for yourself two
men as witness. If you can't find two
men,
one man and two women. And many people
translate
Tazil as if she forgets. The real
translation does not forgets
makes a mistake.
So if one makes a mistake, the second
will remain because in Islam, the man is
supposed to be the bread earner.
In Islam, it's the duty of the man to
take care of the lodging, boarding, all
financial aspect of the woman. So he's
supposed to be financially more
wellvered.
There may be some women who may be
financial wizard. But those exception to
the case generally still man it is a
financial burden. He is financially more
aware. So that is the reason since he's
an expert.
Allah says get two men has witnessed for
financial transaction. IF YOU CAN'T FIND
TWO then one man and two women
you cannot say I can have four women as
witnesses
and if two women is equal to one man
then four women is sufficient. No you
cannot either two men two men or one man
and two women. Let me give you an
example. If you want to undergo a major
surgery, correct? If you want to undergo
a major surgery, the best is you take
advice from two qualified surgeons.
Major surgery,
two qualified surgeon better. IF YOU
CAN'T FIND TWO QUALIFIED SURGEON, one
surgeon and two MBBS doctors less
qualified. Correct? If you can't find
best taste to qualified surgeon, if you
want to undergo a surgery of your colon
colon colonaut tummy or some gastric
dummy, what do you do?
Two qualified surgeon better can't find
two one qualified surgeon and two MB
doctors. Best is two. Similarly, here
because the men are more qualified in
witnesses for financial transaction,
best is two men. If you can't get two
men, one man and two women. So in Islam
only in financial transactions are two
women equal to one. There are some
fukahas, some jurist who said even in
cases of witness for murder
because when they say murder the woman
may not be able to take it. So even in
cases of murder, two woman witness equal
to one.
Otherwise in all the other cases one man
and one woman is equal.
As I mentioned, there are no less than
eight places in the Quran where Quran
talks about witness without specifying
male or female. For example,
Allah says
in the Quran
in Surah Maida chapter number five verse
number 106 107
that oh you believe
when death approaches you, you take two
just witnesses
before you bequet. to write the initance
amongst yourself if you are traveling
can be two just witnesses from others
here it doesn't specify male or female
Quran says in surah talak chapter number
65 verse number two that when you give
divorce take two just witnesses it
doesn't specify men or women Allah says
in surah nur chapter number 24 verse
number four that when anyone lays the
allegation against the chastity of a
woman
if you cannot get four witnesses
each one will be flogged 80 lashes
here in witnesses it doesn't specify
whether it's male or female
similarly if you read in surah nisa
chapter 4 verse number 6
verse number 15
in surah n chapter number 24 verse
number 8 in surah nur chapter number 24
verse number 13 all these places talk
about witnesses without specifying male
or female. One verse of the Quran
specifically mentions
one male witness equal to one female
witness. Allah says in surah nud chapter
number 24 verse number 6
if a spouse
if anyone
lays a charge against the spouse
if you cannot get any evidence your
solitary evidence is sufficient. That
means if a man lays a lays a charge
against his wife
and if he cannot get any witnesses his
solitary witness is sufficient.
Similarly if a woman lays a charge
against the husband and you cannot get
any witness her witness alone is
sufficient. This proves one witness of
man is equal to one witness of woman.
So it's a misconception that always two
women witness equal to one. No in
certain cases only mainly in financial
transaction and some folk says even in
murder cases. In terms of sighting of
moon in the beginning of Ramadan
one witness is required. In the ending
of Ramadan
for the spitter two witnesses required.
It doesn't make a difference whether
it's a man or a woman.
So in Islam generally one man's witness
is equal to one woman's witness. Except
in certain cases like financial
transaction or murder one man is equal
to two women.